[Music]
what if your reality was nothing more
than a complex computer simulation how
would you know what kind of technology
could make the simulation possible and
how could you break out of the matrix
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were living in a
simulation this is what the very first
computer games looked like and this is
what they've come to look like after
some 50 years of technological progress
today
it only takes a virtual reality headset
to jump into a computer simulated realm
our future computers may be able to
generate entire simulated universes and
if we humans were able to simulate
complex realities how could we ever be
sure that our own world wasn't just a
computer simulation designed by another
more advanced civilization everything in
the world we live in seems to be based
on mathematical laws even our genetic
code has a mathematical model just like
if someone had programmed our reality
with a computer code see where I'm going
with this we may be living in a giant
video game without realizing it but who
designed this matrix an advanced alien
civilization maybe not aliens but a
future iteration of humanity simulating
the lives of their ancestors which would
make you a living memory of someone
else's great-great-great grandmother
this future humanity would require
extremely powerful supercomputers to run
the simulation down to the subatomic
level much more powerful than the most
advanced supercomputer we could imagine
if we ever got to this level of
technological advancement and started
running computer simulations of our own
that would be very strong evidence that
our reality was also simulated a
simulation creating their own simulation
chances are our creators would turn out
to be someone else's simulation
in the many many simulations from the
original reality on down each subsequent
simulation would turn out less and less
advanced they just wouldn't be able to
match their creators in advancing their
technologies if your life was a
simulation
you wouldn't know just like there's no
proof that you're not living in a
simulation but you could try looking for
the good glitches if our world with some
computer code it could have software
bugs every now and then when our
simulators decided to roll an update
something could slip sideways it could
be a glitch like meeting your
doppelganger someone who looks like you
but isn't related to you it might just
be a mix-up and character appearance
preferences if we ever found out that we
were a program on someone's hard drive
it could be because that someone wanted
us to in that case escaping the
simulation would be well simulated we
just end up on another level of the
matrix
maybe discovering the identity of our
creators would make them reboot the
system a big control-alt-delete for the
entire universe reality may not be a
quantum computer simulation but if it is
would it change anything in your
day-to-day life maybe one day we'll
discover that we live in the multiverse
but that's a story for another what-if